okay so for people who are joining this
livestream we are looking at features
that are currently tagged as
experimental in more than language and
we're discussing what it will take to
make them not considered experimental
okay first up file operations
hmm what is wrong with file convert
charlie main thing we would like to
change is to look at out of the core
convergence for instance for video out
of core conversions to audio and so
forth yeah design-wise i think this is
solid and it's gonna work
there were talk about the out of court
case yeah well even for video 12 there
were cases like import is getting frame
indices range 1 through whatever is the
number of frames in and export used to
rasterize those numbers and put them
back into the new video files they don't
think we have tested for all file
conversions to see what is the behavior
so testing is one aspect and then the
other okay so what you're saying is if
there are particular elements of format
one that we want to flow into format 2
in other words you're saying this this
function is dealing with things like
images where it's kind of obvious if
you're going from PNG to gif it's kind
of obvious what you want to do correct
right as soon as you want to specify
elements and options we don't have it
yet in file convert I understand the
question is whether it's designed
compatible with what we have here so
what you're saying is um I mean in
principle you might want to run actual
code there I mean at some level it's
like will just write the code and run it
but what you're saying is we might want
to take certain format elements here I
mean I guess we could perfectly well say
format 1 and then various elements are
Oh format 2 and then various elements
which is equivalent to export with those
elements import with those elements by
making sense you do not shoot oh great I
don't have it
objection for that I'm happy to look at
that and maybe about that support seems
it's straightforward I mean them a
question I mean you know I would say
right in this case I mean this is what
you'd have to do you know you could also
have that be an element specification
there all right um okay let's talk out a
core for a second
um what will this look like in the out
of core case nothing different than what
you have in file convert syntax it's
just gonna recognize we're going from an
MOV to OGG and then call a back-end that
does that a lot of core and it may as
well just work for video but I I don't
know if you want to start developing a
little framework that handles more
things and when I say it may just work
as is out-of-the-box for video is
because our video object is just out of
core so we're gonna import as an out of
poor video which is just the file name
and then export that file name pass that
to our back-end and export that nothing
is coming into the core other than the
filing right um okay well so why are we
keeping this experimental it sounds like
it's pretty solid to me yeah as I said
as far as testing I don't feel
comfortable we haven't really done a
whole other tests but experimental
ization apparently the experimental
stuff is mostly about is the design
solid I'm not hearing a lot of
objections to the design here well
another thing that we have discussed
design wise is that we have import
options that I think is for semantic
import or somewhere else music do we
want to have import
options and export options as options to
file combo and if so how far is that
going to be from export of import
anyways if you're adding all of those
folks in to myhumber
yeah well I don't think we should I mean
I think we should just document the fact
you can do you know export of import
yeah I mean as it properties animations
I think it is there already as well well
but I mean yeah okay I mean honestly I
we haven't spent any time on that since
well that's why I don't feel like it
deserves being the experimental eyes to
a wand but I agree that we have we have
used it a little bit it seems okay and
solid
no big objections for moving it from you
well okay the options thing I'm not sure
about okay so because I can see
yeah I mean the main thing people are
gonna want it for is out of course stuff
and for that you know they are going to
eventually want options I think so and
I'm sure you can imagine there are
formats that have similar options for
import and export like image size or in
coatings and things like that that
that's why we need to separate import
options from export options well the
question is whether we syntactically
have them packed and with the format's
here which is a little weird even I just
notice that this function takes options
and it has a third argument that looks
like an option which find a bit
confusing it's unfortunate but I think
that is one of the features of modern
times yeah we're having more of these
rule arguments okay Sandra now live
stream is asking about what the syntax
looked like for converting a 60 frames
per second video to a 30 frames per
second video that's gonna be a frame
rate option 4x4 as we don't support it
now but in export of import it's going
to support all of the options that is
needed to do conversions of password
yeah I mean this is a weird case because
what we've got here is a convenience
function um I mean it's also the case
that okay here's another point doing a
directory would be interesting too
definitely that example we haven't
documented here you know file convert of
a list of files or file convert of a
directory is asking is it parallelizable
and that's obviously relevant if we have
directories right Shaun in in the early
designs Shaun really wanted to have this
take a directory or a route and do the
conversion for all and I think we killed
it and said with this system file
operator system file master map right we
does we'll be able to do basically the
same thing instrument we didn't over
complicate the design of file combure
yeah I mean it might as a courtesy it
might do that I mean it should probably
do it for a list
you
Ali is asking whether there's any
session coming up for read - who's that
is a good question I mean I was
wondering that - I don't know the answer
maybe other people on this livestream
can go find out the answer to that I
don't know I'm gonna check with hundra
we and we were also going to have a yeah
another more general discussion about
priorities I don't know why that didn't
get scheduled either okay um weird not
my issue I am I'm merely no I'm I'm I'm
merely following my calendar he says at
least in the first approximation um okay
remote file
you
yes I mean we our SSH functionality is
not complete yet main reason being that
at the moment we don't have a developer
that works on the SSH functions and we
had quite a bit of discussion of
integrating these authentication options
also into URL so that the because these
obviously also might need authentication
and so at the moment it's still it's not
complete so I would really like to keep
it experimental so we can if we need
change some of the options and add more
add more of these authentication options
if we can yeah
well I agree I mean where is the
discussion about URL getting
authentication options I mean I remember
that was like a week or two ago we
talked about that but do you know where
that's being handled well I wasn't aware
that there was a renewed discussion of
this yes though there is um I mean how
does any of this stuff relate to for
example things like the system
credential stuff
I mean system credentialing wherever we
have authentication options like here
you see that SSH key password which is
something that people might want to
store securely because that's their
that's the DBR we need to keep secure
and so any anywhere where we specify
something that should be kept secret we
should integrate it to a system
credential there was of course the main
obstacle publish that URL accepting
options is probably not that easy to do
because URL is supposed to be in your
Apple and everything every piece of code
that now has a rule for accepting URLs
probably as a rule with only one
argument and so I'm sure that can be
looked at yes yeah we should look at
that and we should inventory how
complicated that is but I think there's
also the issue of how does does it you
know type set right URL is really a sort
of symbolic and typesetting it's it's
mostly a markup for is that a file or is
it a is it a URL thing that's the way I
see it being used I mean the typesetting
is also quite nice and being able to
have you know being able to for example
have that link be able to give it the
authentication options feed in into that
link would be wonderful
you know if the URL had symbolically
specified authentication options but
they just get packaged correctly there
would be really good I mean this is
probably not that easy because I mean
some of these URLs for must have
internal authentication options
and some and so and sometimes we might
want if you have a URL download then he
could accept the internal segregation
options but it could also take them from
there
for the second argument which I mean
it's just like in your web browser I
mean if you al does not have to ascent
occasion options than your powers of a
prompt so I think these two cases are
are separate okay let's let okay listen
the only way functions get to you know
we need a roadmap for what we're doing
with this function okay so what is the
answer to that we're basically we need
to look at go ahead
well basically right this was something
that was put in to solve an immediate
problem for room for SSH link
functionality and they think we have you
know there hasn't really been any work
about how it fits in all right
so we got to get a meeting about that
and its relationship to URL and URL
authentication and so on
okay um
okay various people on live streams
still commenting on the file conversion
business paralyzation is relevant to
single video files for each frame could
be each keyframe could be a separate
thread yes absolutely the case hopefully
but that hopefully will be handled in
sha DS other code um need to have string
pattern names for the rewrite rules for
the for the first argument of file
convert yes I can imagine that I mean
just as we are doing that well are we
doing that for file system map I think
we are Xander is suggesting a an amusing
syntax in which there's format in goes
to forehead out and then there's a list
of options in goes to a list of options
out definitely amusing definitely a new
pattern
kind of the double optioned thing is
kind of a new and different pattern not
convinced about that one
neither neither am i but we'll need to
be hard to type right well we have as I
said we have the simple import options
already in its system you know one of
these days I'm hoping that they'll be at
least I see one checkmark here one there
I do see one there I don't know why all
of these are okay so the annotation
stuff the calculus of annotations I
agree is still somewhat fragile not
fragile but but somewhat embryonic um
I think
ah boy I mean image identify the
designers is okay how do you identify
audio identify the design is okay it's
just that the output is kind of cruddy
yep
fine this probably needs to stay
experimental experimental because of
cruddy output I mean the thing basically
can never recognize you know it just any
noise I make it thinks as it is a human
you know any any noise like coughing
sneezing you know whatever it just
thinks it's you know speech
yeah that the thing is that the data is
being collected for these trainings
we are data rich in image applications
much better than all your data so I
expect these to improve but yeah the
current version is cruddy and I think
for that reason let's keep it
experimental fair enough
I mean
okay
you
okay
um
okay
remote file is handling files on remote
boxes in ec2 through an SSH jump host I
have not ever heard of a jump host I've
used SSH to get to ec2 but okay and this
still doesn't work apparently
I see so in other words having a
something running on our on your desktop
system calling through to ec2 you know I
literally just this weekend because I
was starting to run some remote jobs on
AWS actually using the batch mechanism
there um the I mean I was looking at
what we have and actually um well jesse
was building
something's wrong with any of you guys
have seen that yet um but that's more
for run a job that's for remote submit
not remote file can anybody comment on
on the failure to work through two
levels of SSH on yes I mean the issue is
the SSH box here so that apparently our
version of SSH doesn't support I mean it
cannot be configured so that that's
another one of the the shortcomings of
our account SSH implementation I mean if
you want to do that then you would have
to use two system SSH but that's
obviously something we should support in
the future so well what's involved in
doing that is that a thing is that what
what is the issue is it a different than
sensational library or what's the story
no no I mean it just needs different
different different arguments it you
need to tell SSH that it has to go
through another house so it first locks
into that host and then it issues and
other command to go on her own hope for
further so that is a standard standard
sing in OpenSSH but all of these options
if we want to have them in the language
we need to distill out and provide
arguments in remote one and remote and
copy file and this has been done the
same stories with port forwarding which
our SSH doesn't support it so we need to
get that fixed that sounds like we need
we need a developer and I think yeah we
all shadi
I mean constantly probably could work on
SSH yes you could
why not that would be a good yes would
be good okay why don't we define this
why didn't you try and make cider it was
not aware of this issue it sounds like
fairly low hanging fruit to me
I mean we we should just provide all
useful features of SSH directly in the
language I would think so
um
Ethan is making comments that I don't
understand in detail AWS link only works
for simplification as three works but
real-world companies use Bastion host to
protect their VPNs um
yeah so Ethan has a variety of comments
here about connecting Rock kernels to
port forwarding yes
isn't possible yes the main main missing
fee what is this bastion host its thing
what does that mean well that that's
like the jump jump post before so this
like like a proxy you have to go through
I see
now of course the alternative is always
to use VPN and VPN and goes through this
bastion host and so that that's what we
use internally right I mean if if you
have VPN then you can directly reach
everything inside the VPN and you can
also set up VPN inside Amazon ec2
virtual clusters okay okay so look it
sounds like there is a little bit of
extra sophistication needed Constantine
sounds like a very good person to do
that
why don't you initiate that yes very
good um okay back to audio okay pitch
record we done with with SSH because I
believe we're done with yours myself
okay
thanks Roman by the UM okay pitch
recognized
as the note says it currently only works
with one well with monophonic signals
and what do you anticipate would be the
output for a polyphonic signal
simply a multi very valued time series
but if and that wouldn't be a very
uniform one at different times you may I
mean the problem is is it's two notes
you know imagine you have a chord and
you you know in well I mean if you think
about what's easy to represent in music
notation that's a reasonable thing for
this to be returning and in music
notation the concept that you have a
chord where you put your I don't know
how you write this now they think about
it
you
you you know you play the chord
initially and then you take one of your
fingers off that chord partway through I
don't think that's a commonly well maybe
I don't know I only know that can oh I
guess even approximately um the
does anybody notice that is that a thing
for which there is a common notation
well anyway but but absent that a time
series multiple values is going to work
just fine
right that's the only case where you
you'd find it awkward is if you had
something which was a note it's played
for two seconds
but there's another note that starts
being played one second into that note
right that would be hard to represent
with a you know a multivalued time
series but the other case where it's
just like standard music notation type
thing seems like it should be easy to
represent with you know where it's just
like well this chord got played at this
time as opposed to just this note is
being played at this time
now I mean is something we haven't put
any default development time or any
thought into it I'm I'm happy to create
I as this twelve to and really give it a
thought and well I think we have to do
first honestly that this is going to be
most interesting in the case yeah we
need the music yes yes okay
all right we can leave this experimental
speech recognizer out ratios need to
come how are we doing on that I don't
think the recognition quality is poor
compared to other recognition systems I
think it's quite decent I mean other
ones have a bunch of UX wrappers around
them that we don't have because of the
use case that we have right okay well
anyway I'm sorry so what is the story
with punctuation again sorry to say we
haven't done anything who have been
derived to so many other projects video
have been very has taken I don't think
that's necessarily wrong prioritization
was I think we don't you know for speech
recognizer this and I'm surprised we
don't see the the new speech interpreter
here but where is the okay fine the um
okay but any case to me
you know the killer use cases of speech
recognizer have not arrived yet they may
arrive to a larger extent when you know
when we start doing things with with
videos an audio I mean like for example
okay so I have a use case for the video
stuff as we probably know like like
these live streams and their archives
right I would like to get from the video
I would like to get something which can
summarize each of these right and one
thing we haven't done is there's no good
reason we haven't run speech recognizer
on every one of these live streams I
just got this big bag of of speech which
could be used for searches and I'd like
to know how it does on that I mean we
just haven't done it because it's all
kind of a pain because there's video
files somewhere and we don't know how to
slice off the audio and we got or do we
know how to slice off the audio -
everyone knows yeah what sir twelve
twelve one can access audio part of a
video file only right so okay so what
does that look like what is what does
the code look like for that so let's
imagine I don't even know what these
things are stored in but let's imagine
it's mp4 I don't I'm trying to think I
haven't done it yet but the plan is to
have audio of a video is gonna be the
audio representation of that video file
and whatever you could have done with
any other objects in the system now you
can do with that that's great that
sounds really good I think I'm thinking
video audio right what's that
don't try right now I'll test it and
make sure it works but okay so then so
then the one-liner is speech recognizer
audio of the random file that is what's
this thing okay and and so I'd like to
try that I mean and and clearly as we
get to our ization and things like that
it'll get better but even just getting
the bucket of words seems like it would
be potentially useful because it will
allow us a bit for example let's get the
bucket of words and you know make a word
cloud for each video
yep and
you know that would be interesting to
see I mean it may be that there's mostly
stop words and mostly who knows what
mostly you know things like phrase but
what what cloud takes care of that you
you can delete the I know I know I know
that I know that I'm just making it I'm
making fun of myself and saying um you
know I'm trying to think of repeated
phrases that you know do you get what I
mean
that makes sense no that's the one does
that make sense right well have sense is
a big word um the okay but anyway we
should try this and I mean right now we
believe speech recognizer runs in
roughly real-time as in okay we should
really try it see how it does and for
summarizing these videos we also want to
get you know screenshots and I I don't
know do we believe that again I'm going
down a rabbit hole something different
but do we believe is the key framing
mechanism is there a mechanism whereby
sort of interesting moments in the video
let's say it's a one-hour video where we
can get the five interesting moments
from the video is there technology for
that we looked into keyframes keyframes
have a tag in them so yes with the new
function video frames you suggest that
we will be able to say get me all the
key frames how those key frames are
tagged as key frames I believe is up to
whoever has created the VFR
um
okay but but but my question and this is
probably a machine-learning story is can
we get something which will find us the
interesting moments right in a one-hour
video
I have certainly I mean I I guess I've
seen I have no idea whether they're
always done by hand
um but that seems like a reasonable
thing to ask the machine learning scheme
with the machine learning team I think
without machine learning as well we
should be able to find scene changes and
interesting you know or or combine
things like what objects do you see what
do you track when new things show up in
video things like that doesn't
necessarily require machine learning but
they can get expensive it all depends on
how much time you really I am just um
let's assume I rode spent a reasonable
amount of time to help people find
things and videos summarize check right
actually sander suggests the amusing
idea that word cloud of audio could just
work why not
I mean actually an interesting question
is whether word cloud of an image could
just work using text recognizer
it's yeah it's just one call away from
its word cloud of text recognised
language I'm I'm not sold on these
combinations being built in no fair
enough
Dona
um especially when their end up being
options and things
Ethan is pointing out their existing
neuron that's the do video salient see
an action recognition any of these
suggesting a video contents thing right
you
you
yeah Brian is suggesting interesting
moments to correlate the text in a video
to what actually shows up in the
description of a new function and help
that is a good future thing to be able
to do alright let's look at him verse
spectrogram
this is a cool function
and I guess why does that say list
I thought the icon eyes form of a list
was brace dot dot brace
am I wrong did something break there
that probably means it's an old icon
eyes that wasn't really ated I see
because when we redid the formatting for
version there were some tweaks so it
still evaluates correctly but the
display isn't right unless you di can
eyes it Andrey I can eyes it this is
something in dire need of ionization yep
well that's why we created it why isn't
there we go beautiful okay so that's an
issue for documentation folk to think to
do that okay inverse spectrogram I mean
it's it's kind of frivolous making a you
know sonification of the baboon type
thing
what is it even let me just go there and
how I hold on a second how do I do this
share um audio with zoom oh sure
computer sound here we go okay here goes
here's the baboon
I don't think the Boone's make that kind
of sound
um well clearly this one does right
there
well so Sims partitions with what is
this about this is all the arguments of
spectrogram if you look at that this is
the assumption it makes so so if I make
a a data
I should spectrogram data
so if I just make something which says
um how's the spectrogram represented
here as lists all right yes
but so if I just want to take
let's think so let's make let's say I
make let's do I say I do this
um
you
okay and I want to treat that as a
spectrogram and I want to say inverse
spectrogram of that
you
now what do I do here I want to play
that as audio what is that crazy I said
to audio you have to wrap that into the
audio object
I didn't last long
now how do I determine that is there a
sample rate yeah in audio
so I could say a percent - and then what
would I say herro what would I what
might I say let's say two or four eight
I was pretty cool actually I'm just kind
of ugly but it spits that was pretty
cool
we should use that as an example I mean
if we can find well that sounds a bit
better we should but but something like
that
ah I see that worked pretty nicely
so in other words if I have a 2d array
oh you can guess what I have to do here
I don't think I've ever tried this as
like this so you say I have a 2d array
like that and then I just say in the
spectrogram
you
okay
why is this girl take two minutes it's
only 400
oh it's 400 across but
okay
good science fiction soundtrack type
angry Terrell it's just gonna say it
sounds like Ligeti its various but you
have seven one I'm thinking the same
thing
alright let's see what happens when I
get to the middle here oh I see at this
point
after the middle that's going to be
downhill from here
I get rid sounds better than G CDs I
have to try one other thing um
Oh
that was pretty cool
sorry I'm playing here so to speak
[Music]
[Music]
interesting actually I think it's going
to sound better if we do this
you
I don't like those clicks that we're
getting I have a suspicion what those
are I think it's wrong
[Music]
was pretty cool yeah it seems like
almost one of those tweetable thingies
I'm okay those clicks at the beginning I
think are um something I don't like
pretty much see that it's white noise
mm-hmm okay but it's clicking I don't
think that's right but the
better example than the ones you have
here if I might say so um and I'm gonna
store that for my possible tweeter II um
sorry just a second here um okay ah all
right well so with that I can Dov agree
of a spectrogram seems ready for
primetime but please use an example like
this at the beginning because I think
it's a nice example whereas this one
it's like you don't know where that data
comes from you have no idea what the you
know what kind of a thing it could be
that's true
um this would be better I should
remember which the it might be better to
have the seller or Thomason rule which
is the flip around of this okay um gosh
I should remember what that is my gosh
losing my mind
okay all right then I'm already late for
something else yeah well I'm not a grip
I mean this whole audio pause audio do
all that other stuff
yeah the options are those functions
those are functions I mean so for
example this one I think if I say audio
play of our amazing work of art here so
for example that now I could presumably
say by the way oops how do I stop this
[Music]
by the way I assume that I can just say
audio reverse I met what is it called
how do I reverse this audio oh so I
guess I just have to say audio of
reverse of percent 11 let's go one step
up so it is after all self-similar it
shouldn't make that much of a difference
I like it it's pretty good for yeah sure
for very um that's pretty good looks
like we are getting at the techno music
now yeah yeah right
actually I'm really curious now I'm I'm
um um okay I just one more thing and
then we wrap this up and I apologize for
them
this won't sound like much
you
actually I wanted to reverse that I need
to go to my next meeting
sorry borin
you
one last thing and then we really wrap
up
you
[Music]
[Music]
this works in 12 Oh doesn't it
just stuff yes does it work in the cloud
should work so if I were to like take
probably to make Blake like make a
little thing here and just say audio of
that
you
oops what is the defaults on plates no I
don't care about the reverse wait for
what
and is that a good idea for audio
inverse spectrogram
well depends where the spectrograph or
the data comes from
certainly made a lot of sense in the
days of Redbook audio I mean it's not so
obvious it makes sense for this
particular thing here well in their
spectrogram doesn't have a sample rate
option oh I see
I could okay tell me what's happening
here
up okay let's try it
why isn't that plane
just stuck
you
can you comment oh my this isn't plain
been looking into some optimizations on
the clouds it's I haven't checked with
the cloud team to see what has happened
with that after the conference
I'm and rule 19 I don't I mean rule 60
would have flipped around so that it's
some as that it goes to the right left
okay well this didn't work so I'm gonna
send this out as a problem here okay
well weekly experimental eyes one
function better than zero
um we have a place in our community for
this type of odd experiments are you
asking do we have a place in there in
the community website and things yes
saying do we are you stating that we do
or are you asking if we do I'm asking
I'm asking no I don't do but we should
have because there's always a lot of fun
things one can do super fun yeah this
was this was good I think I'm gonna
tweet this one if I get around to it
um okay great uh okay so if people who
are following our live streams we are
doing a big live stream about
biomolecules in less than two hours
um otherwise I'll talk to y'all soon see
you later